[Music]
on this sunday night the trail of
destruction
the whole house lifted up off the
foundation then was then dropped back
down here more deaths confirmed after a
powerful storm system tore through parts
of southern ontario and quebec it is
something that everybody should be
concerned about plus the outbreak of
monkey pox the latest crisis threatening
to derail the biden administration's
agenda
as female referees we've always just
wanted to be considered a referee and
taking the field female referees set to
make history at the fifa men's world cup
global national reporting tonight
tracy tong
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us the death toll has risen to at least
eight after saturday's devastating
thunderstorm in southern ontario and
quebec today residents are still picking
up the pieces
dangerously high winds heavy rain and
hail battered communities across the
region including the nation's capital
hundreds of thousands are still without
power
ross lord looks at the widespread damage
and whether it's a sign of things to
come with climate change on everyone's
mind
in stitchville ontario people are less
concerned with what type of storms swept
through their ottawa area community than
they are with the devastation it left
behind and how the weather changed so
suddenly from idyllic to dangerous
paul mcmahon has lived in this house for
three peaceful decades and then it's
like oh get in the house because like in
an instant it just got really violent as
he grinds through the thunderstorm's
aftermath
mcmahon says at least one of the family
vehicles is a write-off from destruction
more synonymous with an east coast
hurricane than a thunderstorm i don't
know if that was like a microburst or
anything like that or what it was but
i've never seen anything like that in my
life hydro ottawa says 200 power poles
were dislodged or destroyed
even some transmission towers fell
victim to a deadly storm that did
similar damage in parts of quebec with
freakish weather becoming more common
around the globe it's tempting to file
these images under climate change damage
or is it simply the result of seasonal
forces you'd certainly see it in the
springtime of the year when the warm air
is never too far from the cold air and
they duke it out and you get weather
wars breaking out we get extreme
summer weather i mean we're the most
second most tornado prone country in the
world we get maybe three or four
tropical storms every year we get um
lightning strikes three million
lightning strikes a year
back in stitchville residents are shaken
still trying to make sense of what they
see oh
utter disbelief you know the tree was
just uprooted and the car
very hard to believe the devastation and
all around the streets this is not the
way anyone wants to spend a holiday
weekend that typically kicks off a
carefree season they hope it's a blip
not a harbinger of more turbulence over
the summer
ross lord global news
one of the area's hardest hit by this
storm was the small town of uxbridge
ontario which has now declared a state
of emergency the destruction there is so
bad it's fueled speculation that this
was more than just an ordinary
thunderstorm
mike drollet spoke with residents on how
the terrifying conditions tore through
their homes
this section of the valley has all been
hit there was a sense of wonder as
margaret hall surveyed the damage behind
her uxbridge ontario home more than 20
trees snapped in half but hall says all
she heard were the 120 kilometer per
hour wind gusts you didn't hear anything
all you saw was the results
nothing it was that intense
the cleanup promises to be intense as
well with the most immediate concern
untangling the power lines from the
fallen trees we expect it to be out for
a significant amount of time so there's
there's
hundreds of trees down if not thousands
um and then we've got some buildings and
roofing material on hydro lines so
there's a lot of work to be done
this is what the storm's opening salvo
looked like in video taken from the air
hours later it's clear part of the town
about an hour northeast of toronto was
hit by a more intense weather event
definitely lots and lots and lots of
straight-line wind damage but this may
be that one spot where everything came
together to produce one of those uh
tornadoes on the front end the damage is
obviously pretty extensive here in
oxford with trees ripped off and houses
damaged but the true measure of the
power of this storm to be best
illustrated here with this house
witnesses say they saw it lift up into
the air
and when it landed
it came down off of its foundation and
while it's more evidence for the experts
to consider as they determine what to
call the storm it's also someone's home
like many others it may soon be declared
uninhabitable across the street jason
woodhams is waiting for the insurance
agents i don't know we're all in just
shot right now
but yeah is your initial impression that
you're gonna be able to fix it
i don't think so i think it's kind of i
think it's too far gone
a brief storm that will leave its mark
for years to come
like drew like global news uxbridge
ontario
stateside the u.s northeast is
sweltering under a heat advisory today
record high temperatures are expected to
hit new york philadelphia boston and
connecticut after the mercury soared
into the 90s fahrenheit or mid-30s
celsius
tourists are trying to beat the heat and
high humidity by hitting the beaches in
droves
however a cold front monday is expected
to bring some relief from the scorching
temperatures u.s president joe biden is
in tokyo the latest stop on a tour of
asia but as he's set to meet with
japan's prime minister he's facing a
growing chorus of criticism at home over
his handling of a string of domestic
challenges jennifer johnson reports
president joe biden arrived in japan
sunday kicking off the second leg of his
trip to asia strengthening america's
alliances to counter china's increasing
power in the region back home a cargo
plane from switzerland landed in indiana
containing 1.5 million bottles of infant
formula a drastic shortage of formula
has left millions of parents struggling
to feed their babies dozens have been
hospitalized i have never seen anything
like this they come in dehydrated you
give them iv fluids and we can give them
nutrition by vein but that's not a
long-term solution
the delivery is a much needed win for
the biden administration a new
associated press poll shows the
president's approval rating is at its
lowest point since taking office just 39
percent of americans like the job he's
doing but democrats are putting out a
different spin as november's midterm
elections loom this is a a tough moment
for our country but president biden has
been very decisive in his leadership we
rescued the economy put shots and arms
money in pockets but supply chain issues
have led to skyrocketing consumer prices
in the u.s everything from baby formula
to household appliances are almost
impossible to find inflation has hit its
highest level in 40 years food prices
are soaring gas prices are now the most
expensive in u.s history the prices are
getting crazy 120 24 dollars not even
full tank that same poll shows only 2 in
10 american adults feel the country is
headed in the right direction
adding to biden's woes another rise in
coven 19 cases and a crashing stock
market even america's biggest retailers
like target and walmart are watching
their profits take a steep dive
hospitals are very nervous and in
response they're trying to dramatically
reduce their expenditures and
that affects the bottom line most
experts believe rising consumer prices
will last well into next year that will
likely hurt democrats in the midterm
elections and possibly cost them control
about the house and the senate and a
republican-controlled congress will only
make president biden's job more
difficult
jennifer johnson global news washington
ontario may have its first case of
monkey pox
health officials today trying to confirm
the diagnosis in an ontario man in his
forties
he is now in stable condition and is
believed to have had contact with
someone who recently traveled to
montreal
in quebec health officials there say
they have five lab confirmed cases with
15 more being investigated
south of the border at least two cases
of monkey pox have been confirmed in the
u.s
and president joe biden says the disease
is something to be concerned about
well they haven't told me
the level of exposure yet but it is
something that everybody should be
concerned about we're working on it hard
to figure out what we do
and what uh
vaccine of any may be available for but
it is a concern in the sense that if it
were to spread
it's consequential
coming up the new challenge for bars and
restaurants already reeling from
pandemic restrictions and closures
[Music]
plus a scathing report looks at what
went wrong at the site of one of
canada's deadliest coveted outbreaks
russian forces are launching a major
assault to tighten their grip on the
donbass region of eastern ukraine
surveillance video captured the moment a
missile impacted a grain facility in
nepro as the russian military continues
to target civilian and humanitarian
infrastructure after finally breaking
the resistance in the strategic
southeastern city of mariupol russia
appears to be launching a major
offensive to seize all of luhansk one of
two donbass provinces
france's minister to the european union
says ukraine's bid to join the bloc will
take 15 to 20 years
that as ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky is insisting on an immediate
start to the process for full eu
membership
polish president andre duda who was in
kiev agrees appealing to the eu to open
its doors to ukraine now
the french and german governments have
pointed to the huge job of rebuilding
the country's war-shattered cities and
economy as well as legal and economic
reforms to reduce corruptions as key
milestones for eu membership
over 80 percent of covid-related deaths
during canada's first wave happened in
long-term care homes and now a new
coroner's report out of quebec paints a
devastating picture of how things
unfolded at one of the hardest hit
residences as dan specter tells us
advocates hope the lessons learned will
help improve senior care across the
country
it's now deserted but inside this
montreal building that used to be the
heron senior's residence a pandemic
horror unfolded that scarred this
province this country forever
it's very very painful
paul khan yellow is talking about
learning the details of his
grandmother's final days in the recent
coroner's report into deaths in quebec
seniors homes during the first wave of
covet 19. she and 47 other people died
at heron under deplorable circumstances
it's extremely angering it's extremely
frustrating
and uh extremely hurtful to know
somebody that willful and that unique
and that
tough
would die with such little dignity and
such little compassion and such little
care the events at heron have been
subject to multiple investigations but
coroner jihan camel's deep dive into the
events is perhaps the most detailed and
scathing yet
when it comes to heron people failed she
said in her 200-page report camel
criticizes the disorganization of health
authorities noting the horror of
allowing human beings to die in inhumane
conditions alone malnourished and in
their own feces i'm not shocked by this
i'm not shocked by the info i'm just
just disappointed and and very
frustrated the report says carnello's
grandmother did not die of covet 19 she
died due to the lack of basic care as
many staff deserted the residence
authorities communicated with lawyers
and debated whether to call 9-1-1
decision makers need to be held
accountable for the decisions that they
took that led to the situation
kamel said even though the government
knew seniors were among the most
vulnerable to the virus they chose to
keep care homes in a pandemic planning
blind spot hopefully uh heron can be
used as an example
for change
and
for for other places as well and for
other provinces heron was taken over by
the government during the crisis and
after the coroner's report a top
regional health official announced she'd
step down from her role the coroner's
report has made 23 recommendations and
kamel says the change recommended is
owed to the seniors who died their
morning families and the thousands of
health care workers who did their best
in the face of the impossible dan
specter global news
well after two very difficult years of
pandemic related restrictions and
closures restaurants and bars all across
canada are now facing another challenge
as global's maragahi reports in bc the
struggling food services industry is now
calling on the provincial and federal
governments to take action to help
alleviate a crippling labor shortage
patios are critical to us to be honest
because we go from
maybe 85 seats on the inside to upward
of 130 seats with patios and on this
sunny afternoon the patio at roamers in
vancouver's river district filled up
soon after opening
you think it's a sign that business is
good and it is always ready for a busy
weekend good for you guys but ahead of
me long weekend this type of demand has
bc restaurants feeling the crunch of a
now historic labor short i've never seen
a time and place in my 40 years in the
industry like it is today
we're short about 30 percent
the bc restaurant industry estimates it
needs 30 to 35 000 workers
[Music]
on the heels of the pandemic worker
exodus there's also belief that
processing delays on foreign worker
applications are a factor keeping jobs
vacant everybody's short workers and the
big solution for us is to get this
foreign workers program uh in place and
and acting as it should
the bc restaurant association wants the
province to ask ottawa for an exemption
to what's called the labor market impact
assessment which confirms there is a
need for a temporary foreign worker for
any given job and that there is no
canadian or permanent resident available
to do that job
this would be temporary and could help
fill the void by speeding up the process
we're pushing the feds not only to
reduce the time but we're also pushing
them to give us more levers and more say
in what type of workers we need because
we know what we need working all these
eyes sometimes drains you it's very
exhausting also i was working seven days
a week
um now i'm down to five days a week um
but i mean that's what you got to do
when times are tough you got to help
each other out and fill in spots when
needed you all ready for a big weekend
kate
in the meantime those already picking up
the slack we'll continue to ask for
patience especially during the busy
weekends ahead emadikahi global news
women run the world cup ahead the first
female referees of soccer's biggest
tournament
[Music]
just six months until canada's men's
national team will make its first
appearance at a fifa world cup in 36
years and this tournament will also be
making history by having female referees
take charge of men's world cup games for
the very first time redmond shannon
reports
referees warming up together just before
the last men's world cup a boys only
club for almost a century that is until
now
fifa says for the first time three of
the 36 referees at soccer's biggest
tournament will be women with three more
female assistant referees along the
sidelines in qatar canadian carol ann
chenard worked at nine different fifa
tournaments including olympic games and
junior mail events as female referees
we've always just wanted to be
considered a referee
but the opportunities over the last four
years have just grown leaps and bounds
across the the world in many ways this
announcement is the end game thanks to
pioneers like chanard women like her
have been refereeing men at lower levels
for years but the world cup will mark a
new milestone with the whole world
watching the head of fifa's referees
committee said i would hope that in the
future the selection of elite women's
match officials for important men's
competitions will be perceived as
something normal and no longer as
sensational the journey to get here has
been about building experience but also
respect something that hasn't always
been shown to women in charge in 2020
argentinian star sergio aguero was
criticized for putting his arm around a
female official when he didn't agree
with her call of course there are
comments oh it's a girl oh it's a female
that kind of thing and yes there have
been statements and comments made to me
during a game but i manage that just
like i would any other type of statement
it is remarkable that this progress is
being made at a world cup in qatar in a
region where some countries lag behind
engender equality teams from iran and
saudi arabia could play their world cup
games with female officials countries
that until recent years banned women
from even watching men play never mind
taking charge redmond shannon global
news london
finding your true fit
next the group helping people thread
together their gender journeys
[Music]
the clothes you wear can sometimes be a
reflection of your personality
preferences and identity a student-led
initiative is teaching members of
calgary's lgbtq community how to alter
clothing to make them gender-affirming
as jill croteau reports some consider it
a lifeline
there's a saying that goes you can have
anything you want in life if you dress
for it
what if that want is to simply be
accepted as your true authentic self a
desire to look how you feel on the
inside
that's why every stitch is so
significant so i identify as a trans man
non-binary in that sense but yeah i
transitioned from female to male when i
was 15. this workshop is organized by
threads that thrive
it's run by state students for students
and it's where people learn how to alter
clothes to fit their bodies garments
tailored to be gender affirming it
lights you up having something that i
want to wear and represent myself in
makes me feel like i want to get out of
my house and i think that's helpful for
a lot of lgbt people who do suffer with
agoraphobia depression anxiety and other
things that are so relevant to our
community shopping in designated men or
women's departments can be intimidating
and sometimes risky for those who are
navigating their own gender journeys
when you are
a queer person shopping in
a clothing store that maybe doesn't
match your outward gender expression um
fear of being outed fear of being
persecuted it can be dangerous
people are not always fitting in these
neat little buckets so it started years
ago when they started acknowledging that
hey not everyone is a size zero to
whatever there are people that fall
outside of that so they started to make
things maybe a bit more size inclusive
and now i think they are making strides
towards making things more gender
inclusive while they're learning the
skills they need to make clothes that
fit
turns out it's truly about the space
that fits it's life-saving definitely
there's something in me that's still
afraid that my right to be trans will
get taken away like they're going to
take away my hormones they're going to
reverse my surgery and give me girl
clothes again and the fact that i know
that i have the support there it's not
so much the clothing so much as the
the pathways that are opening up for me
to get it joe crotell global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm tracy tong
tonight's canada is the sunrise in
sylvan lake alberta we love seeing your
canada so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching colleen christie
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow have
a great night